hey everyone
welcome to the simply learn live on
instagram marketing tips
before we get started let's wait for a
bit as people join in
thank you to everyone joining us from
youtube and facebook
once again i'd like to welcome everyone
to this live session on instagram
marketing tips
before we begin i'd like to remind all
of you that we have a dedicated team
here to answer your questions
so if you have any ask away in the
comment section below
instagram is a social media platform
that needs no introduction
with nearly 1 billion monthly active
users
and 500 million daily active users
instagram is a platform drive with
marketing potential
more than 7 billion revenue has been
generated from instagram mobile
and it's home to more than two million
advertisers
not only that marketing on instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research
more than one third of the people using
the app have used it to purchase
products
which means by marketing your products
on the app there's a higher chance of
conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part
thanks to instagram's parent company
facebook instagram has access to just
about all advertising features offered
by facebook ads
with this you can advertise to people
based on their age location
gender interests and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships
you can stimulate conversion with your
followers and build a connection with
them
you'll also get a greater understanding
of what your followers like and dislike
based on their engagement
this enables you to make content they
enjoy more and increase the chance of
converting a user to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page
that's where they make the first
impression of your brand and that's why
it's important for your bio to be
informative captivating
and engaging use your bio to provide a
brief description
of your brand or product the type of
content you'd be posting
brand hashtags links to other social
media platforms and
more your bio should also include a url
to where you want to drive traffic to
be it your brand's website or a page for
a particular product
make sure to track this link as well to
see how much traffic it brings
here's an example of how samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services samsung
offers there are links to other pages
and a link to the website as well
it's to the point and covers everything
you need to know about it
next up at number two we have create a
content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
content calendar
a content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts
it'll help you plan ahead and automate
the process of publishing your posts
when your audience is most active
a calendar helps you decide what content
caption hashtags
videos goes live on what day date or
time
a consistent post schedule will enable
you to make the most out of instagram
it'll also keep your audience engaged
and also give you access to historical
posts
if you want to repost your older content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement
leads and conversions the caveat here
being that you'll need to pay for it too
the ad options are pretty similar to
what you have on facebook
like audience segmentation based on
likes interactions buying habits and
more you also have a variety of ad
formats to choose from like story ads
image ads video ads collection ads and
more moreover they can also be set up
from facebook ads manager
here's an example from an ad from
bodyshop in which they are using a
single image ad
the advertising works because of its
interesting creative
and attractive ad copy that attracts the
customer to interact with the post and
click on the link
let's go to number four have a visually
consistent feed
instagram is a platform in which people
gravitate towards aesthetically pleasing
content
to authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry
what works nowadays are candid shots
muted earthly tones with a low-key
editing style
your content must feel down-to-earth and
your brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have aesthetically pleasing images
and a somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for
your content following an understandable
and interesting aesthetic depending on
the product you're trying to sell
now for number five tell a story the
images videos and stories you post need
to tell stories that can captivate your
audience and establish a connection with
them
this makes it more likely that they feel
closer to your brand and buy
your products your captions can tell
stories that can help your brand appear
more human and build deeper connections
with your audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face
here's an example of how the page
patagonia talks about forests in america
each of their posts tells stories about
a different issue that affects nature
their brand on instagram revolves around
bringing awareness to such
issues that's the kind of stories you
should tell with your brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags
using the right hashtags can make the
difference between your posts showing up
on the explore tab for everyone to see
and it getting lost in the sea of
content
your hashtags shouldn't be too generic
like new year or hash
style since they'll have too much
competition instead
mix up trending and industry specific
keywords to connect with your followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems
spammy untargeted and unprofessional
find out what and how many hashtags your
competitors use
and how you can do something similar you
could also create a hashtag for your
brand
these need to be short easily memorable
and involve
your brand name in some way let's now go
to number seven
take advantage of ugc ugc or user
generated content
gives your followers to further involve
themselves with your brand
ugc also by them as well regardless of
the field your brand belongs to
ugc can be used to convert followers
into advocates of your brand
here's an example of how starbucks uses
user-generated content and takes
advantages of their audience to
advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed in products stored at
starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and improve
brand loyalty
next up number eight take advantage of
video ads
most instagramers state that users have
visited websites
searched or told a friend after being
influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising
video advertisements aren't too far
behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to instagram
ads single video ads that can create 60
second ads
carousels are a combination of images
and videos
and instagram stories that enable you to
combine images and videos to create
visually attractive ads
here's an example of the brand pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with
well short videos and captions now for
number nine
partner up with influencers connecting
with influencers will enable you to
connect with thought leaders within the
industry
and enable you to show off your brand to
a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and they have a
closer connection with their audience
here we can see how ralph lauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products
the influencer showing off the latest
ralph lauren has to offer
this encourages his interested followers
to check out the page and buy something
for themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways
contests enable your audience to engage
with your brand with 3.5 times more
likes and 64 times the comments
you can give away a product or a service
which enables you to boost engagement
and brand awareness
contests and giveaways need to be
planned brands need to be partnered with
contest rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important
you would need to track your contest
performance and promote the results on
other social media platforms as well
here's an example of a contest run by
domino's pizza which encourages people
to contribute their own short stories
and connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours stories can
greatly influence your reach and
engagement rates even giving your story
the chance to show up in the explore
section
it can also help make your brand seem
more approachable and authentic
adding links to the instagram stories
can also help with driving traffic to
your website
igtv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline
still has a few advantages to offer to
the savvy marketer
igtv provides you a unique mobile
friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well
like featurettes and interviews another
new tool they have introduced is
instagram reels
instagram's answer to tick tock
instagram released reels through which
users would be able to upload 15 second
clips
and since it released very recently it's
rife with marketing potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn
identify effective hashtags visual
styles and the best times to post
doing this you can develop the best
practices for your brand
social listening and analytics will help
you fine-tune your marketing strategy
and increase
instagram engagement and there you go
that's our video on instagram marketing
tips
with that we have reached the end of
this video do you agree with our list
think we missed anything important let
us know in the live chat or in the
comment section below if you're watching
later
thank you for watching this video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn